[Music]
it's funny cuz this is just a
coincidence but you and Adam work
together on staring out live but you
also you knew each other before you run
a lot we went to NYU drama school
together right yes yes Adams the one who
got me on Saturday Night Live he
recommended my yes yes Andrew Schaeffer
and your Jerry's yelling you're like
Molly I'm gonna get you on the show just
give me a little Wow you were the she
was the queen of NYU everybody loved her
and school and college everybody talked
about Molly Shannon was she's the best
but yeah we were in drama school
together and we did them we did a little
comedy revue show that's how we it was
like a revue show in a small black box
theater where we make fun of the
teachers and it was like a big hit on
the campus oh yeah it was the best yes
yes so so you know now it's my way and
that is exactly the same as he was years
ago that I can attest to you've not
changed at all that is true yeah thatís
true make the first day I met you you
were dressed exactly like this
you sense me like you want to get a
milkshake the first things he said to me
I was excited they were milkshake
he loves now like like the rest of us
you have children now thank you
Stella my daughter is nine and my son
Nolan just turned eight okay any sign
that they're gonna want to be in show
business are they showing I think they
show busy kids or really their I don't
think they would go into show business
but they're definitely like creative
with the way they play and stuff like we
just had spring break
and um mice and uh we didn't we didn't
go away we just went away for a couple
days but we mostly stayed to the house
and kids played with our friends and my
son Nolan is always around a lot of
girls which he loves could because of
his sister so there's always all these
girls
so it's Nolan and then a bunch of girls
no one in a bunch of girls yeah well the
ganas no one normally just turn eight
okay so I came in the room the other day
and he was he was he was lying down with
like on his back like this with all the
girls massaging him like a bunch of rope
what game is that game looks like what
game were you guys playing and they had
spa music on and they had lit candles
and then no one was like it's a game
where I pretend to be a drunk person who
stumbles in looking for Easter candy and
he looks for candy and then he can't
find candy and then he lies on and gets
a full body massage from a group of
women I'm a group of girls what is G
don't fear their friends and fellas this
kids a genius first of all I wish it had
the presence of mind as a young guy to
be like let's play a game
ladies I'm drunk I stumble into a spa
and you take care
it's fantastic my uncle used to play
that game with me
your uncle played no no but your uncle